es ist der erste anschlag eines erste
ihnen den die menschheit als solchen
registriert hat zwar schlug der tunguska
suite in einer menschenleeren gegen den
rebellen ein
doch der anschlag war so heftig dass er
hunderte kilometer entfernt noch als
donna lichtblitz und erschütterung
wahrgenommen wurde
wäre er nur mit einer leicht
geänderten flugbahn zu einer anderen
zeit oder in einem anderen winkel in die
erdatmosphäre eingetreten
ja das hätte zahl der größten
katastrophe des letzten jahrhunderts
geführt es hätte millionen und
abermillionen auftrag gegeben
furchtbare zerstörung und wir hätten
ab diesem moment wahrscheinlich
fieberhaft daran gearbeitet eine solche
katastrophe zu verhindern aber kann so
etwas wieder passieren und wenn ja wann
jetzt den klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen ja heute ist der sj
day der tag an dem wissenschaftler und
personen des öffentlichen lebens an
eine furchtbare und leider sehr
wahrscheinliche katastrophe erinnern mit
dabei ist zum beispiel brian may
gitarrist von queen und astrophysiker
nach seiner wahnsinnig erfolgreich und
musiker karriere hat er im alter von 60
jahren eine doktorarbeit über die
radial geschwindigkeiten im
interplanetaren staub geschrieben und
seit diesem jahr ist der spd auch durch
die vereinten nationen zum
internationalen s day ausgerufen worden
ist ist ein unglaublich wichtiges thema
und noch immer haben es nicht genug
menschen auf dem schirm der erde wird
durch asteroiden bedroht und wir haben
darüber berichtet sie schlagen ständig
auf der erde ein und zwar rund zwei mal
im jahr nur niemand bemerkt es als
meistens in dem viel größeren
unbewohnten teil der erde geschieht doch
das kann sich jeden tag ändern denn die
nasa schätzt dass es millionen erdnahe
asteroiden gibt von denen zahlreiche
kandidaten seinen einschlag auf der erde
geeignet sind von diesen millionen also
jeden kennen wir nur einen klitzekleinen
bruchteil 10.000 1
deshalb ist dieses jahr die 100 mal
dekoration die 100 x6 ins leben gerufen
worden
ich habe mir gerade gesagt und das
solltet ihr auch tun der linke ist in
der video beschreibung es wird gefordert
dass aus diesem einen 100% werden und
wir in den nächsten zehn jahren alle
aktionen erfassen und damit die finden
sie sich auf einem kollision
mit der erde befinden aber auch an
anderer stelle kommt die sache langsam
aber leider nur langsam ins rollen die
nasa hat ende letzten jahres eine sonde
zum asteroiden benno geschickt der alle
sechs jahre der erde rund 300.000
kilometer nahe kommt und das esa nasa
projekte isa sz impact reflektion
assessment auf deutsch
asteroideneinschlag und ablenkungs
einschätzung soll den asteroiden die
dumonts nicht nur untersuchen sondern an
ihm soll auch zum ersten mal getestet
werden ob der einschlag einer sonde
seine bahn verändern kann es werde
etwas absolut erste mal dass die
menschheit so etwas versucht ja wahnsinn
allerdings wissen wir noch sehr wenig
über die beschaffenheit von asteroiden
der 2014 entdeckte das weltraumteleskop
hubble ein ziemlich gruseliges exemplar
das vor den augen der wissenschaftler
langsam zerfiel 200.000 tonnen wog p
2013 r3 so der name so zerfallen machen
sich jetzt seine bruchstücke langsam
auf die reise in verschiedene richtungen
und teile von ihm werden wahrscheinlich
auch auf der erde einschlagen beim
tunguska ereignis war die region um den
einschlag herum ungewohnt erst knapp 20
jahre später dann eine expedition in
das gebiet vor und sah die immer noch
sichtbaren verheerenden folgen
auf einem gebiet von 2000
quadratkilometern waren 60 millionen
bäume umgeknickt der asta etwa nicht
auf dem boden eingeschlagen sondern in
der luft explodiert und hatte deshalb
diese verheerende wirkung noch immer
weiß man sehr wenig über den anschlag
2013 wurden angebliche bruchstücke des
asteroiden präsentiert die aber immer
noch nicht untersucht worden sind und
auch ob der jacko see der krater eines
bruchs stückes ist das bleibt
umstritten
es bleibt also noch viel zu forschen und
vor allem zu tun wenn wir einen solchen
einstieg in zukunft verhindern wollen
und nicht zu vergessen erst 2013 ging
ein asteroid in einem bewohnten gebiet
den keller pinsk in russland wieder 1500
menschen wurden verletzt
und obwohl er sehr klein war stürzte
das dach einer fabrik ein es bleibt also
leider sehr spannend wenn er zum thema
asteroiden und den gefahren die von
ihnen ausgehen nichts verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dem video über die zahlreichen
anschläge die jedes jahr hier auf der
erde unbemerkt stattfinden einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran